we're in the stunning mountains of
Austria for an amazing never before
attempted stunt I am blown away by this
now before we take your breath away
let's meet our top Daredevils II well
droid nur pause diner and Curt tipple
who's chance meeting at an air show set
in motion one of the most incredible
aviation experiments the world has ever
seen one father financial routine is
that we fly canopy the canopy the so
called mirror flight and we always say
we fly that close that not even a man
can fit in between and Paul said I'm
sure I would fit it's not that close and
so the idea was born yes this insane
idea clearly crowns them as the greatest
Daredevils of all in three easy steps
step one exit a glider at 10,000 feet I
never thought I would see a video of a
man getting out of a glider in the air
normally you see a skydiver get out of a
plane and just go off and fall through
the sky but this one's so keen on planes
that he in fact wants to get into
another one step to catch your
connecting flight midair the most scary
part was where the guys hanging from the
wing and the other gliders coming up
underneath you only need a little bit of
turbulence for this to go horribly wrong
but it didn't
and not satisfied with a mid-air
transfer these Daredevils decided to
take it to the next level level insane
otherwise known as step 3 sometimes like
sake I was incorrect over if in this
work have Rick Jack Johnson on this way
I've worked the talked on this what I
need on this wall
Suarez was lucky
I heard that all was successful but I
didn't believe that he really touched
morality so what science did our
Daredevils have up their sleeve to pull
off the world's first wider the glider
transfer with a rudder touch finish the
reason this stunt worked is because of
frames of reference you might think I'm
stationary but if you look at me from
another frame of reference the earth is
actually spinning on its own axis as
well as going around the Sun so if you
look at me from outer space I'm actually
moving so that's exactly what's going on
here
the two gliders are moving at the same
speed so in that frame of reference this
guy is absolutely stationary they might
as well be sitting on the ground in the
parking lot however it's one thing to do
in one foot from the ground it's another
to do with thousands of feet in the air
yeah this stunt is 10,000 feet up and it
sure looks pretty breezy up there at the
speed that he's moving you can calculate
the wind resistance and it turns out to
be about 100 kilograms of force and so
now imagine that you are feeling your
own body weight pressing against your
chest as you're trying to do this
maneuver it's not the easiest thing in
the world to do hang in [ __ ] antigua
Jima midshipman to constantly glare on
the city desk a weakness not always
getting in the way of it or getting what